let me talk about this is about 10 years
out of date but but nevertheless i don't
think it's
still not a bad gloss a work on
distributed computing you know
cryptography has really assumed that
divided agents into two sets there's the
good guys and the bad guys
the good guys follow the protocol they
do what they're supposed to do
and the bad guys do all they can to
subvert it
and that made a lot of sense
historically that
the system designer writes a protocol
but
some computers might be flaky and not do
what they're supposed to do there might
be an active adversary who doesn't do
what they're supposed to do
so this model was meant to be a worst
case kind of thing
but people made a lot of progress using
this
i suspect all of you heard of things
like byzantine agreement that was sort
of very much motivated by this model
um by way of contrast
game theory assumes that all agents are
rational
no good guys are bad guys just rational
agents and they're trying to maximize
their utility
and to me both both views make sense in
different contexts and and we want to
combine them so let me give you some
intuition so uh as i said byzantine
agreement is the paradigmatic problem in
distributed computing
so for those of you who haven't seen it
uh there's n soldiers up the t of them
may be faulty
uh n t or common knowledge uh each agent
starts with an initial preference
actually what i'm giving you is the
consensus version of it
and we want an algorithm that if
followed by all the non-faulty guys
guarantees
that all the non-faulty guys do the same
thing at the same time
so they either all attack or retreat or
all retreat
and if the soldiers are all non-faulty
and their initial preferences are
identical that's what they do so this is
the second clause is a way of presenting
the preventing the trivial solution
where no matter what everybody attacks
of course if everybody attacks then
that guarantees that all the non-faulty
guys do the same thing
so we just put on this minimal
requirement that if everybody initially
wanted to retreat
and they're all non-faulty then they
should end up retreating you can't
just take the trivial algorithm of
everybody attacking
so um and just to briefly review this
this is going to come up later there's a
ton of work hundreds of papers on
byzantine agreement
and one of the things they considered is
what kind of
faulty behavior do you have byzantine
failures allow you to do anything you
can
lie and cheat and steal and then we know
excuse me agreement is possible if n is
greater than 3t
or t just to remind you again up to t
might be faulted so t is an upper bound
on the number of faulty agents with
crash failures agreement is always
possible
with byzantine failures again byzantine
means arbitrary
crash failures are failures where
if you're faulty you have the good sense
to shut up and die
so you don't lie you always tell the
truth you always follow the protocol
perhaps up to a certain point where you
crash
that's why they're called crash failures
at the point where you crash
you might send out some messages and
then crash
um and it's known that agreement when
possible is reachable in t plus one
rounds
t plus one is a lower bound so there's
just a ton of work on this
now if you look at this from a game
theorist point of view byzantine
agreement is a game between two teams of
unknown composition
there's the good guys and the bad guys
we know there's the most tea bad guys
but we don't know who they are
so it's a game and we can write down a
utility function
so that's one thread i want to relate it
to a second thread
um which goes back to the 80s
multi-party computation that's a
paradigm
paradigmatic problem cryptography and
the picture here is that each agent has
a secret input
their goal is to compute some function
of that input without revealing any
information
other than the output so you want to
know everybody has a salary that's their
secret input
you want to know what is the highest
salary being paid so you want to know
the max
so the function is the max function and
you want to compute the max
without revealing any information about
each individual player's salary right so
that
the picture you should have and that
they very much did have explicitly in
these early papers
is imagine you had a trusted third party
a trusted mediator
so each agent can send that trusted
mediator their salary
and the mediator will tell everybody
what the highest salary is
right um but somehow you want to do this
without having a trusted third party
that's the goal and there are protocols
for multi-party computation
assuming that less than half or less
than a third of the agents are bad so
this one third
should remind you of this again we can
do business agreement if less than a
third of the agents are bad
it's not a fluke and it's very much the
same model
so let me talk a bit more about
mediators so
consider an option where people do not
want to bid publicly
so why don't they want to bid publicly
well public bidding reveals useful
information
right so if you're bidding for the
rights to drill for oil um
i guess these days that's not such a hot
area at a bitter anymore but certainly
you know 10 years ago
there was a lot of bidding on that you
don't want to reveal to other companies
where you're hoping to drill right i
mean if you bid a lot for a certain site
presumably that's because your
geologists have looked at that site
carefully and figured that's a good
place to
to be drilling for oil you don't want
that information to
uh to leak out so again if there were a
trusted third party
we'd be all set that that everybody
could tell the trusted third party
what their bid is and the trusted third
party would just reveal
who won who bid the highest
right so um and again
visiting agreement can be solved easily
with the mediator if n is greater than
2t
it's trivial each player tells the
meteor mediator his preference
the mediator chooses the majority
so that leads me to my third thread
work on implementing mediators in a
sense you can view all the work in
cryptography
in the 80s as really work on on
implementing mediators
can we and what they meant by
implementing the mediator is can we get
a protocol that has
the same effect as if there were a
trusted mediator that is precisely
nobody knows anything other than the
functions output
now in game theory this was made quite
explicit
they talked about implementing mediators
now they're looking at it
in the context of game theory with nash
equilibrium
so technically what they had in mind is
there are three games
there's what i'm going to call the
underlying game it's a normal form game
what i mean by that is everybody makes a
move
you have a matrix that describes the
payoff as a function of everybody's move
everybody gets a payoff then there's a
game with the media
in the game with the mediator you can
use the mediator
you can talk to the mediator they might
tell you stuff
but after talking with the mediator you
again make a move
just like in the underlying game and
your payoffs are the same as the
underlying game right so the picture is
it's it's
think that there's an underlying game
but now we can use a mediator
to maybe help us achieve better results
than we could
on our own in the underlying game and
for those of you who are familiar with
notions like correlated equilibrium
you can think of a correlated
equilibrium as what you can get
with the mediator where you don't even
have to talk to the meteor the media
just tells you what to do
so you can definitely in general achieve
more with the mediator
that you can achieve without it again
those of you know correlated equilibrium
is
um with a mediator you can get a
correlated equilibrium
in general correlated equilibria include
nash equilibria but but are more general
and you can't achieve a correlated
equilibrium without a media so
definitely having a mediator can help
and the question the economist asked
they looked at a third game so the first
game was the underlying normal form game
the second game is the game with the
mediator the third game
is what they call the communication game
where players are just talking to each
other
which should remind you an awful lot of
the work on a multi-party computation
um so they asked can we achieve the same
result
the same nash equilibrium as we got with
the mediator
just by talking to each other using what
the economist called cheap talk
uh the reason was called cheap talk is
you know i can look i can promise review
really for sure i'm going to make this
move i'm going to go left
it's cheap talk if i don't do it we
can't do anything it's not like there's
a judge
that can force me to do it um so
and notice also the dates here mid to
late 80s
not so different from the dates here um
and the kinds of results they got
so i just stressed this is almost
identical to multi-party communication
certainly if you look at the papers
they're talking about
mediators in both cases if we had a
trusted third party
if we could do something with a trusted
third party can we do it without the
trusted third party
the only difference really if you stand
back a yard or a meter
uh is that in the game theory literature
the emphasis was on rational players
rather than faulty players
so in the cryptography literature we
wanted to be able to get this result
despite up to a third or up to a half of
the guys
being bad and trying to bring down the
system
um whereas in in the game theory world
there's no good guys and bad guys it's
just rational guys and we want to get
the same nash equilibrium
using cheap talk that we got without it
and also
in the game theory literature there was
no concerns about privacy whereas this
was a big deal
in the uh in in the multi-party
communication literature
but interestingly the game theory
solutions
provided security of provided privacy it
turned out that in order to get the
results they wanted they needed to keep
things private
in any case the rest of this talk is
about combining the threats
um so first i want to
start by generalizing the notion nash
equilibrium
in a way that's actually been done
before
i want to talk about k resilient
equilibrium so nash equilibrium
tolerates deviations
by one player so for
regime is fair for me to assume that
everybody here knows nash equilibrium
they wouldn't be coming to the stock
otherwise yes i think yeah
i have a question about your previous
slide though
i think in the multi-party computation
there was a lot of
uh uh efforts
focused on looking at different
functions and
you know so uh in the case of
um this game theory literature what
kinds of functions were they considering
was it
they weren't considering functions at
all technically
um they had what they call the
underlying game so they started out with
the normal form game
and in both the um
game with the mediator and and what they
call the communication game
um in the game with mediator you
communicate with the mediator
and then made a move in the underlying
game in the communication game you
communicated with each other
and then made a move in the underlying
game and the payoffs were just the
payoffs in the underlying game
okay right so that to the extent that
you wanted to talk about computing a
function that would only be true
if uh the underlying game in some sense
captured
the function which you can imagine so i
i should say that
it was perfectly okay to they were
actually interested in underlying games
that were
not i said normal form games they look
more generally at bayesian games where
each player has a type
uh again is it safe for me to assume
that people know what a bayesian game is
so think of a bayesian game as as a game
where each player has some private
information
that's known as the player's type and
and their strategy can depend on their
type
and typically it's assumed that that
there's a commonly known distribution
over types
but i want to relate that to your
question rajiv that you can assume your
type is your input
to the function and then you can assume
that your action
is the output of the function or
something like that so you could
in some cases encode function
computation
certainly the input you can encode with
the type right so that the question is
can you somehow cleverly encode
computing the output um
with with what the you know the player's
actions in the game in some cases the
answer is yes but that certainly was not
their focus
on computing a function so i mean where
i saw the
the um the similarity was both when
we're talking about count you know
if we can do something with a trusted
third party can we do it without
um so going back to where
are there other questions i mean this is
definitely a good time to stop and ask
all right um so
as we said nash equilibrium tolerance
deviations by one player
it's perfectly consistent with nash
equilibrium the two players could do
better by db
right so we could have a nash
equilibrium where neither rupak nor i
could do better individually by
deviating
but if rupak and i got together and said
i said hey rupa you know
i have this great plan if we both
deviate
it's perfectly consistent with nash
equilibrium that we could do better
and we were certainly interested in
cases where
we had coalitions so i'm going to say an
equilibrium is k resilient
if no group of size k can gain by
deviating in a coordinated way
so just a simple example we can imagine
a game where
everybody plays either zero or one
that's your action if everybody plays
zero
then then everybody gets a payoff of one
if
exactly two players play one they get a
payoff of two and the rest get zero
and for any other set of actions
everybody gets zero
so i claim that playing everybody
playing zero is a nash equilibrium that
should be clear if everybody
plays zero they get one
and if one person deviates and plays a
one then there weren't this bottom
bullet here
otherwise everybody gets zero they're
definitely you know the one person is
definitely worse off
by deviating but if rupak and i got
together
and agreed that we would both play one
then that deviation would make us happy
we would get two
and everybody else would get zero so
this is an example of a nash equilibrium
that's not too resilient it does not
tolerate deviations
by coalitions of size two and and i
hope i don't really have to work too
hard to convince you that that
in a lot of real world settings it makes
sense to consider k resilient equilibria
for not too large k i mean it's hard for
me to imagine a thousand people getting
together to coordinate
but i can certainly imagine five or six
people getting together to coordinate
especially if there's
large stakes involved um
so in general k resilient equilibria
don't exist which might be one of the
people
uh one of the reasons rather that game
theorists never really looked at it
carefully
game theories tend to avoid avoid like
to play looking at
solution concepts that aren't guaranteed
to exist and it's not too hard to come
up with examples where even
two resilient equilibria don't exist so
um historically back in 1959 even bob
almond
considered what he called strong
equilibria
and these are um equilibria that are k
resilient for all k
and there has been a bit of work on it
after that
but we were more interested not in the
case of k resilient for okay but we
think if k
is a parameter and we're going to be
interested in equilibria there is
you know three resilient okay is three
and i think that's important but i would
argue that k resilience does not give us
everything we want
let me explain so i want to also
consider
irrational players players that don't
seem to respond to incentives
maybe because their utilities are not
what we thought they were
maybe because they're irrational maybe
because their computer computers are
being flaky
right so that that um i don't want to
count
on everybody's computer working well um
on if i'm doing bidding right if i'm
doing bidding over the
over the internet for some for something
can i assume that everybody's computer
is is working well maybe somebody's
somebody's computer is mangling their
results these things happen
so we get behavior that's not
consistent with the protocol not because
somebody is deviating
because they're rational they think
they're going to be better off with that
deviation
maybe they're deviating because their
computers are faulty or because the
network is being flaky
or because so typically when we analyze
protocols we think we understand
what players utilities are but if you
think about 911
so were the people who flew into world
trade center were they irrational
well um you know we can debate that but
you could make a case that that
they were being perfectly rational given
their utility function
it's just that the utility function is
not what you thought it was
right so um apparently irrational
behavior is
certainly not uncommon uh people share
on on
sites and they see it on bittorrent and
so on um
so is that really irrational you know i
mean i
back in the old days when when people
were downloading stuff music on the web
those of us who remember you might say
well um you could say it's irrational to
post music on the web and let people
download it you might get sued
and besides that you know you might need
a big server just to handle all the
requests
but nevertheless people did it although
it turned out relatively few people did
it um
but you know maybe their utility
function was such that it makes me feel
good that
all that music that you're playing that
came from me
right so that that you know uh we
shouldn't presume that we understand
people's utility functions
and the key point here is that if we're
designing a protocol
we might want robustness that is
we might want the protocol to work
despite the fact that there's some
players who have utilities that are not
what we expect
or despite the fact that some players
might have faulty computers
or don't understand the rules and so act
apparently in an irrational way just
because they don't understand what's
going on
so imagine we have a group of end
bargaining agents
if they all stay in bargain everybody
gets two
if anybody goes home the person who goes
home gets
one but the people who stay get zero
right so i claim there are two nash
equilibria in this game
quick sanity check what are the two
equilibria
clearly everybody's saying to bargain as
an equilibrium they all get two that's
that's pareto optimal
and what's the other equilibrium
let me encourage audience participation
here
there is another equilibrium in this
game
somebody everyone goes home everybody
goes home exactly
right because if everybody goes home
they all get one and if anybody deviates
the deviator gets zero right
now everybody's staying
and getting two that's a k resilient
equilibrium
no coalition of size k for any k
has any incentive to deviate right
because if you
a coalition of size k and you deviate
then
you get zero certainly no benefit to
that on the other hand
um it's a very fragile equilibrium
because all it takes is one irrational
player and i put irrational in quotes
you know maybe you have a sick child and
you decide that you're not going to stay
because you need to go home to take care
of your child
right so you have utilities that are
maybe not what i expect but
uh or maybe you didn't understand you
didn't get the message that you were
supposed to stay in bargain and you went
home
so this is a very fragile equilibrium in
the sense of all it takes
is one let me say irrational but i don't
really mean a rational i mean it might
be perfectly rational
all it takes is one player who doesn't
stay and then all the people stay get
zero
on the other hand everybody going home
the other equilibrium
is incredibly robust i don't care who
deviates
sure they don't have to you know they
can go to stay in bargain
i'm going to get one no matter what they
do so when i say robust here
it's because my payoff is not affected
by what other players do
does that make sense so uh we're going
to introduce another notion
that we call immunity a protocol is t
immune if the payoffs of the good agents
are not affected by the
actions of up to t other agents again t
is a parameter
so um i claim this
everybody going home is t immune for any
t
because i get my one no matter what the
other players do
right does that make sense so this
equilibrium everybody's staying is k
resilient but not even one immune
this equilibrium turns out to be both k
resilient
and t immune for all k and t
less than n i i have a question
the answer is no but even if so suppose
you were to focus only on socially
optimal equilibria the same phenomena
would uh
arise uh if you had multiple equilibria
yeah there might not all be
uh equally good from the point of view
of robustness
right that um
yeah but i mean no but there is this
whole thing about
you know these the social uh socially
optimal things
and then i mean that uh
which is a subset of all the nash
equilibria right right
so if you look at you can look at the
equilibria to maximize social welfare
yeah right um that's another visitor
it's orthogonal to the two that i've
outlined here
right so that you can have something
that's socially optimal
but not robust um you can have something
that's robust and not socially optimal
and so on
so clearly in terms of social optimality
that's this equilibrium everybody's
staying
right but it's very fragile and if you
had a large group of people so imagine
you had a thousand people
and to get the payoff of two required
everybody to stay
would you be so comfortable in assuming
that everybody would stay
or would you go home and and you know
get your guaranteed payoff of one
and not have to worry about what other
people are doing right so um
they're just different this is it rather
right okay yeah
so i'm formally going to define a kt
robust equilibrium as one that tolerates
coalitions of size k
and up to t irrational players so it's
it's uh i'm not going to write down the
formal definition here
in the formal definition we even allow
the
t players to to collaborate with the
uh with the coalition so to be kt robust
even if you had a coalition of size k
plus t you don't do better
but again the intuition here is no
coalition of size k can do better by
deviating so these
k guys care about payoffs
they're rational on the other hand these
t guys
might not be influenced by payoffs at
all
right or at least if they are they're
they you don't understand their
utilities
so to say that we're k2 robust it's
saying no matter what these k guys do
they can't do better by deviating
no matter what these t guys do my payoff
doesn't get hurt if they deviate so let
me stress the difference with
k resilience we're doing just the
standard generalization of nash
equilibrium we're saying
these k guys cannot benefit by
with t robustness we're saying i don't
get hurt
if they deviate i'm not saying they they
may or may not benefit for deviating
intuitively it's because i don't know
anything about their utilities they're
strange irrational who knows i just want
to make sure that i don't get hurt if
they give you
right so that's the intuition here this
is
two digit errata i i you know i i don't
want
it to be beneficial for a group of k to
deviate and i don't want to be heard of
t players deviate so
so sorry there's a question so these t
players act separately or can they also
coordinate
uh in our definite they can coordinate
and that comes out in our definition
and they can even coordinate with with
these k players
if you look carefully at the definition
that's effectively what it's saying
um so the question we're going to have
so in general kt robust equilibria don't
exist
but they can be obtained with the help
of mediators
uh you can think of byzantine agreement
as a zero t robust equilibrium
a can a kt robust equilibrium be
obtained
so the question we're going to ask is if
you can get a kt robust equilibrium
with a mediator can you get it without
the mediator can you get rid of the
media
so this is i'm hoping this should remind
you of the kind of thing that
was going on in multi-party computation
if you can do something with the trusted
third party can you do the same thing
without
and also implementing mediators here the
generalization
um so if you like the the ecom
literature was asking the same question
in the case that k equals one and t
equals zero and there's a sense in which
you can view the
crypto literature the multi-party
computation literature is asking this
question
in the case that k equals zero because
they weren't concerned about
uh utilities they didn't have a notion
of rational agents so
there's essential which we're
generalizing both the multi-party
computation literature and certainly
generalizing the
game theory literature on implementing
mediators
so here are typical results uh i'll i'll
say a bit if i have time at the end
about the tech i think i will
about the techniques we use but uh
suppose there's a kt robust
equilibrium a k2 robust protocol that's
an equilibrium
with the mediator can you get rid of the
media
and the answer is yes
if n is greater than three k plus three
t or three k
plus d and this is true even if exact
utilities aren't known
and the protocol turns out to be bounded
that is it runs in 17 steps
you know some there is an upper bound to
the number of steps and and i guarantee
you that after that
bounded number of steps it'll stop
and it doesn't require punishment i'll
talk about punishment in a second
so let me say what was known before we
came on the scene
in the econ literature going back to 89
they had shown that that
nash equilibrium is implementable if n
is at least
four so you can think why four well
four is three times one plus one
right so so what they showed was the
special case of this result
when k is one and t is zero and that
that was certainly known
uh from the paper by barney and forge
back in 89. interestingly
so let me say a few words about
punishment strategy so intuitively
a punishment strategy says if i catch
you deviating
then i can punish you so there is
something that the good players can do
to make the deviating players worse off
than they would have been had they not
dvd
so i'm going to skip the formal
definition of a punishment strategy
the original notion of punishment
strategy is duterte
who's a game theorist so we're using
that
here and saying look if there's a
punishment strategy
technically there has to be a way to
punish up to the up to k
players if enough of the good guys
implement the punishment strategy then
the k
players will be worse off than they
would have been if they followed the
protocol so
uh now we can do it
so this is an improvement here was three
k plus three t now we're down to
two k plus three t um if there's a
punishment strategy we can implement the
mediator if n is greater than 2k plus 3t
interestingly this protocol randomizes
and the randomization is over the
running time so basically you're tossing
a coin to decide whether or not to stop
at any given round i'll say more about
that later if i have time
so the expected running time is finite
but it there can be unbounded
runs right i mean it's possible the coin
always lands tails
and you'll run an unbounded amount of
time i'm stressing this because
as you'll see we have counter examples
to results in the econ literature
because of this
if there's a broadcast channel you can
do better you can get it down to
2k plus 2t but now there'll be an
epsilon error
that is to say you'll implement the
mediator
in with probability 1 minus epsilon and
with probability epsilon you won't
implement the mediator
and if you have one-way functions and
there's a punishment strategy
you can do it if k plus t is less than n
so what we found interesting here is
these are standard assumptions
from the distributed computing and
cryptography literature right the
existence of a broadcast channel
is something that is not always but
certainly sometimes assumed
in the distributed computing world that
turned out to make a big difference here
one-way functions is something that that
the photographers often assume
uh and again that made a huge difference
here and
roughly speaking and as i say if i have
more time at the end uh the idea here is
we're going to reduce this to
multi-party computation and secret
sharing i'll say a lot more about that
uh if i have time at the end so it
turned out particularly for this result
this result really followed from results
of multi-party computation
that said you could do multi-party
computation of venezuela in sweden
so it turned out that we had to do a bit
of work to adapt the results but
basically the techniques used in the
cryptography literature
suffice what we use to get this result
so in some sense we can go to the
economists and say
uh you know we can explain to you why
you got the n greater than four and it's
really an instance of a much more
general result
and you really need to learn some
cryptography to really understand how to
do that i mean it turns out that
uh let me say a few words here that that
roughly
uh in the end we're going to do secret
sharing so it's
we have a polynomial and the question is
if you have a certain number of points
on the polynomial can you reconstruct
the polynomial
and it turns out that if you have um
so ignoring the t that that roughly
speaking if you if you have
so think about a line uh
if you have three players one of whom is
faulty
then you can see that you know when they
tell you what their values are
you'll see that they might not be
collinear but you can't figure out what
the right answer ought to be
but if you have four players one of whom
is faulty
even if one of them is and each of them
are telling you
their secret is a point on the line
we're using secret sharing
and their secret is a point on the line
if each of you are telling the point
what their point is on the line
even if the bad player lies
you'll have three cold into your points
you'll be able to reconstruct the line
a generalization of that argument that's
where we use the secret treatment when i
said we reduce it to secret sharing
uh that's what we're doing here we're
able to get the n greater than three k
plus t result the three k plus t is
if you give me enough points in the line
on on the polynomial of whatever degree
i can reconstruct the polynomial that's
what's going on here
so in some sense we could say to the
economist that really is
at the heart of your n greater than four
pro and greater than or equal to four
protocol
um even though it might not be obvious
now
uh um anyway
there's matching lower bounds this is
really the best we can do in general
so if n is less than or equal to three k
plus t
three k plus t or three k plus three t
then there is a game
um and a k two robust strategy with a
mediator that can't be implemented
without a mediator
um without knowing the utilities or the
or without having a punishment strategy
so notice what this is saying
we're saying for every single game for
every single underlying game
if you can get a k2 robust equilibrium
with a mediator you can get it without
if n is greater than 3k plus 3t and the
lower bound says
there is a game
where there's an equilibrium that you
can get with a mediator
that you cannot implement if n is less
than or equal to 3 k plus 3t
and likewise for all the other results
and some of these proofs use ideas from
byzantine agreement
for getting lower balance and byzantine
agreement so this is really
distributed computing stuff going on
here
uh let me say a few words about running
time
so it turns out that if 2k plus 2t is
greater than equal to n
there is a game that has a k2 robust
strategy with the mediator
that can't be implemented by any
deterministic cheap talk strategy
so you have to randomize so when i say
here that the protocol is randomized
well it actually has to be randomized
um for all b there's a game
with a mediator that can't be
implemented with expected running time
less than or equal to b
so i can force you to run arbitrarily
long
and similarly if um
if you're allowing epsilon error then
you can get a similar result
now why am i focusing on these results
um well stay tuned
let me just say a few words about
asynchrony before before i go on
that all these results assume that
systems are synchronous
right players communicate to each other
and then all make a decision in the same
route so the round says
i send a message then you receive it
then you take an action
any message sent around t will be
received in round t
um but
and in all these protocols there's a
sort of essentially a cheap talk phase
where players talk to each other
and then they stop and then they make a
decision
but that just doesn't seem realistic
um asynchrony is a common feature in
many real world
applications in distributed computing
asynchrony is a standard assumption
and an asynchronous system there's no
upper bounds
on the running time oh sorry no upper
bound on how long it will take a message
to get delivered
message could messages might never be
delivered
my point is that the markets are much
closer to being asynchronous
than synchronous it's not like there's a
clock ticking in the trade gets executed
around after you sent it
blockchain assumes partial synchrony so
the standard assumption of blockchain
is that anytime i send a message there's
an upper bound
of delta and messages arrive within
delta steps
that's the canonical blockchain model
now
partial synchrony is as the name
suggests somewhere between
synchrony and asynchrony it was
introduced in part
to get around the known problems with
byzantine agreement in asynchronous
settings
but i should point out the partial
synchrony many of the issues that arise
in dealing with asynchrony already arise
with partial sync
for example you might have this with
partial synchrony it could be
ah all the good guys send messages
and the bad guys get the message so
in partial synchrony typically we sort
of group things into rounds
but now the rounds are last delta steps
because it can take up to delta steps
for a message to arise
to arrive but then if i send a message
if i'm a good guy i send a message
i it could be that the bad guys so in
round k
all the good guys send a message and
could be their messages are received by
the bad guys
before they send their message
and what that means is that that with
partial synchrony
the bad guys have a major advantage they
can decide what to do indicate
round as a function of what the good
guys did in the case round because
um they'll they might know what the good
guys did
and you have to deal with that so this
is uh
you so even with partial synchrony there
are serious problems
so it turns out that that that um we
wanted to get the same results
in asynchronous systems or the same
kinds of results
in asynchronous systems so he wanted to
say well if you can do something with
the mediator
in an asynchronous system then you can
do the same thing
without the mediator well
even making that precise was a bit
tricky
because in an asynchronous system the
outcome that you get
might depend on the scheduler so the
scheduler you can think of the scheduler
as just another player
that decides who moves
and how long messages are going to take
to arrive
right so in an asynchronous system um
players are scheduled that's why we call
it a scheduler so i can decide okay
at this step rupak moves then at the
next step
rajiv moves then the people here ana
moves
later and that message that rajiv sent
to me
it'll take five rounds to arrive that's
what the scheduler
so to speak decides and typically when
you want to prove their protocol is
correct
in an asynchronous system you have to
prove that it's correct
no matter what the scheduler does no
matter
what order players are scheduled in and
no matter how long it takes for messages
to arrive now
sometimes you can simplify that you can
say well i want a scheduler that's
fair that you know you don't have to
wait too long
if you want to send a message you won't
be delayed arbitrarily
um so we can put restrictions on the
scheduler but
that's the kind of thing we have to
worry about in asynchronous systems the
point is when we're thinking game
theoretically
and you're playing let's say even with a
mediator
the equilibrium you end up playing might
depend on the schedule
that is the mediator could say well let
me wait for messages if i get a message
from
from rupak before i get a message from
rajiv then i'll
go for this equilibrium and if i get the
message from regime first i'll go
for that equilibrium it's actually not
too hard to get examples like that
so in the synchronous setting
implementing a meteor said meant that
if you got a certain nash equilibrium
with the mediator you've got the same
nash equilibrium
without the media but now
in the asynchronous setting the
equilibrium that you get might depend on
the scheduler
so what we require is that for every
scheduler in the mediator game
if you look at the equilibrium you get
there's a scheduler in the communication
game
that gives you the same equilibrium and
vice versa
so that the set of equilibria that you
get with the mediator game
um you get the same set in the
communication game the cheek talk game
um and it's a question of for every
scheduler here there's a scheduler here
that gives the same result i hope that
makes sense if
not ask questions but
with that caveat we were able to prove
similar results this is just last year
so these are fairly recent results
that that if you have a k2 robust
equilibrium using a mediator
then you can implement it now before the
result said if n is greater than
three k plus three t that three now went
up to a four
so if n is greater than four k plus t uh
and now if you have a punishment
strategy you can do better you can get
that to three k plus four t
before it was two k plus three t so
basically um
the numbers increased by one to deal
with asynchrony
and there's matching lower events so
sorry there's a question so is there a
simple correspondence between the
schedules
in the game with the mediator and in the
game no
no um the schedules are much more
complicated
because if you think about it in the
game with the scheduler
so sorry in the game with the mediator
typically the protocol the
protocols that we're looking at
typically are very simple right
everybody sends a message to the
mediator
the media does stuff tells everybody
what to do and in fact you can show
without loss or generality you can
reduce to these um
to protocols where everybody just sends
one message the mediator
the mediator figures something out and
sends one message back to the players
uh so there isn't much scope for the
scheduler
in that setting the schedule can of
course decide what order
the mediator will get messages in but
only once
um and it can decide what order the
mediators messages are going to rock the
various players
but not a lot of room to maneuver
whereas in the communication game
the communication game everybody's
sending everybody else messages
so the scheduler has lots of room to
maneuver
it's very very different kind of
schedule so there's no easy mapping
from what the schedule in the mediator
game looks like to what the scheduler
and the
cheap talk game looks like
other questions i have i have a question
but
in the asynchronous setting with uh
scheduler
how do you define equilibrium like who
this in terms of the scheduler's
strategy uh so we don't view the
scheduler as
a strategic player that is the schedule
doesn't have payoffs
so it's once we fix the scheduler
that's an equilibrium right that um
that it's it's it would be different if
we view the schedule as a player in the
game and and
they would be part of the equilibrium
they're not
yeah yeah but if if if even in the
two-player setting
if one and there is a scheduler but if i
deviate
or you know then the schedule
the scheduler has to pick a different
schedule because maybe the message is
the same
we think of the schedulers following a
strategy that's a fair question
think of the schedulers following the
strategy that then
so actually we do even more
um we're assuming that the scheduler is
an adversary
so that when we say um
that there's an equilibrium it's an
equilibrium even if the scheduler's out
to get you so to speak
so that that um so in a sense yes
if you send a different message i have
to decide for that message how long is
it gonna take
and and the answer is okay the scheduler
is on your side
and and and it has to be an equilibrium
even if the scheduler so to speak
cooperates with you and delays the
message as you wish it to be delayed
so it's a very strong notion of
equilibrium
but one that's i think consistent um
with what's done in the distributed
computing literature
or the scheduler is viewed as an
adversary and notice that this is an
if-then result so we're saying for each
scheduler
in the mediator game if there's a
scheduler so to speak if
if there's a scheduler if there's an
equilibrium with a schedule or
cooperates with the deviating players
then there's an equilibrium in the
communication game where again the
schedule cooperates
with the deviating players so we're you
know the scheduler is
part of the adversary on both sides of
the equation
other questions
uh so there's tons of related work on
implementation of both cs and game
theory and there's been
a lot of work in the cs community since
our paper came out
a lot of people push these results but i
want to focus on
some results that are wrong in the game
theory literature
um so as i say that going back to
what i find amazing is that the work in
the game theory literature
uh would they prove that that we can
implement
equilibria if n is greater than equal to
four so that's just theorem one a with k
equals one i mentioned that before this
goes back to fois and baloney
roger myerson was involved and roger
myerson won a nobel prize
and francoise polish is a very well
known game theorist uh barney is a sort
of an or
game theory guy also very well known so
my point here
these are not obscure papers in an
obscure corner of game theory these are
you know the
people involved in this literature were
extremely well known people
and similarly in the computer science
literature and again look at the dates
88 um this has been or
gold right from uh this is xiaom [ __ ]
and dumb god but people like you know
the people involved in multi-party
competition people like abby victorson
mickey ben orr sylvia mccauley
goldwasser
odette goldberg these are major figures
in computer science
um and and as i mentioned before that
that by
looking at a result of been oracle ben
or gold russian viktor jason
um where they proved that you could you
could implement a
trusted third party if n is greater than
3t
it was basically the core of our proof
for theorem 1a uh theorem 1a is this one
the n
whoops the event is greater than 3k plus
3t
we can implement the mediator we were
just i mean it was not completely
trivial
but the core of our proof was was was
the btw proof
um now
in the game theory literature um
theorem one b with k equals one
um again uh that's what the game theory
lecture was interested in case one t
is zero so he proved that if n is
greater than
um sorry if n is greater than three and
is greater than two times one
uh and there's a punishment strategy
then you can implement
a mediator uh at least he claimed to
prove that
uh it turns out that there's a problem
with this proof
his proof is bounded his strategy is
bound
that is you don't have to understand
anything about game theory you look at
his proof and he says
this proof here it is it's going to run
in 17 steps
i mean it's not 17 but basically the
players go through rounds and after
four rounds where each player plays once
so it's basically four
end rounds the protocol stops
so it's a bounded protocol you don't
have to understand
anything about the details of this
protocol if you just look at the
structure of his argument he says here
is my protocol
it's bounded well we have a theorem that
says
this was the point of theorem three
there is no bounded protocol
you can't implement a kt robust strategy
with a mediator
using cheap talk with expected running
time less than or equal to b
if 2k plus 2t is greater than equal to n
uh you can't do it so we knew that his
theorem had to be wrong
then later after that we found the book
so there is a bug and we
you know i i know reasonably well i
pointed out the bug he's written uh
in a rotten where he has a much stronger
assumption that
um and he proves his result is correct
under this much stronger assumption
but the interesting thing is we knew
there had to be a bug
even before we read the details of his
proof
because you know just glaringly obvious
that that his
protocol is bounded um
so as he has a correction using a notion
of verifiability that
isn't implementable um
there are results by hello that extends
ben once he saw our work he said ah
it's good to think about care resilience
but he
too had some problems in this proof um
there's work in the cs literature that
that gave us there in one c
one c is this one that where you had one
wave functions existing again in the
case the k was one
since then there's been a lot more work
in the cs literature generalizing these
results
now again urban villa
these are two people um had a paper
where they got theorem 1d what's one
with the other
right this one that that um if one-way
functions exist then k
plus t uh if n is greater than k plus t
then there's an implementation but again
their results
assumed uh they had a bounded protocol
again you don't have to understand
anything about what they're doing
but you can look at their protocol and
see it runs in a bounded number of steps
and our theorem showed that that's false
and again after we figured out
it had to be false it took us a while uh
but we found the bug in their protocol
their protocol got published in their
paper got published in econometrica
which is arguably the leading journal in
the field and then plots was in jet
which is journal of economic theory
another
major journal in the field so again this
stuff wasn't
in obscure journals and i find it
fascinating
sociologically that you know arguably if
you look at
notions like multi-party computation and
implementing mediators both of which
you know late 80s in economics and
computer science um so these no
these guys went on for two decades
basically actually
our first paper came out in 2006 so for
about
16 years blissfully unaware of the other
side's work
right even though they were doing you
know more or less the same problem
and as i say the cs techniques very much
apply to the
problems that that the game theorists
looked at
so there's other work in as i say since
our original paper there's been
literally hundreds of papers written on
this um
so let me stop and say that issues of
coalitions and fault tolerance are
critical
in distributed computing and game theory
and photography
i think by combining ideas from all
three areas we can get lots of insights
i i think in particular game theory has
not looked at asynchronous systems
my own feeling is really there's like
one or two papers in the game three
literally look at asynchrony
it's a major topic in computer science
and distributed computing
i think there's a lot more that can be
done in game theory if you consider
um asynchronous settings which i think
really
you know lots of real world settings
that they apply um
now i think now
there are a lot of papers that have
considered rational players
as well as byzantine players in the
distributed computing literature
um lorenzo elvisi and his students
pushed another topic which i think is
really interesting
he says look in the real world you have
a certain number of people
who will follow the protocol if you tell
them to do so think of them as being
they use the word altruistic i prefer
the word obedient but basically
if i tell you you know you should pay
taxes it turns out that at least in the
states most people pay taxes
or they don't treat very much um in
greece
nobody pays taxes so
lorenzo wanted to look at a notion where
he said well suppose a certain number of
players
are guaranteed are going to follow the
protocol so it's another parameter just
like we had
saying that most t players are going to
deviate um
most k players are rational they might
form a coalition
now we allow first you know i'm going to
guarantee you that a certain number of
players are
guaranteed to follow the protocol
they're going to be obedient
and it turns out that you know maybe you
can take advantage of that
that knowing that a certain number of
players will do what they're supposed to
do
uh that can be something a mechanism
designer can
you know use to design a better
mechanism um
there hasn't been very much work on that
but i actually think that's that's a
really interesting area actually i'd
like to push it a bit
to say that i will follow the protocol
as long as i don't feel like a total
jerk
when i do so so i i this is the example
in greece i think in greece nobody pays
taxes because they figure nobody else is
paying taxes
so why should i pay taxes when nobody
else is paying taxes
whereas in the states people tend to i
mean they've done studies a lot more
people pay taxes
i think partly because they're assuming
that most other people are paying taxes
so what i'd like to have to consider and
it'd be interesting to make this precise
a notion of conditional obedience where
you follow the protocol as long as you
don't feel like you're being taken
advantage of
and i think it'd be really interesting
to study that
um so we have implications for game
theory
so i've used up my time i mean i i could
spend a few minutes talking about
the structure of the proof that people
want i'd be happy to answer
more detailed questions so pretty much
up to you or i'm happy to also quit
it's one o'clock so i don't know how how
things work
uh rupak it looks like you want to talk
to your muted
yeah so um maybe at this point we can
take questions and
uh if there are questions about the
proof we
visit that during the discussion
thank you very much this was a really
fascinating
uh talk so if you want to ask questions
please
uh write something in the chat and i can
call upon you
or you can just unmute yourself and no
no i mean
at least the physical audience doesn't
seem to be too large so
yeah um perhaps i can start with a very
quick question
so your games are eventually one shot so
what is the meaning of a punishment
strategy
uh this is a punishment so um the
underlying game is one shot yes
but the communication game is very much
not one shot
that that uh it's an extensive form game
so
so there it literally a punishment
strategy if i catch you cheating
i will punish you right i will play a
strategy that guarantees that you get a
worse payoff
than you would have gotten had you not
cheated so it it's um
yeah so it's important that our
communication games are extensive form
games they're not one-shot games
okay thank you
i also had a short question about the
punishment so
is the punishment strategy does it
influence anything
or any punishment strategy just the
the fact that you will be caught um
let me try to answer i'm not sure i
understood the question so i'll try it
if i haven't answered the question ask
again
um that that it literally is
um if i catch you cheating it's a
strategy that i can implement
that results in you getting a worse
payoff than you would have gotten
otherwise
it does influence things so basically um
so here's the way to think about it um
i can it turns out that i can i can tune
a parameter
to say how likely is it that i'll be
able to catch you if you deviate
so let's say you know with probably
one-third i'll catch you if you deviate
well then i just make sure the
punishment strategy is such that
the amount you know with probably
one-third uh i catch you and then i'll
invoke the punishment strategy and so
your expected payoff
is while a third of the time you'll get
punished two-thirds of the time you
might make out like a bandit because
you didn't get caught and i want it to
be the case that that
um you'll end up worse
you know so you'll decide it's just a
bad idea to deviate because of the
probability of getting caught
uh so i it turns out that i can tune the
parameters
so as long as there's any kind of a
punishment strategy even if the
punishment strategy even
makes you epsilon worse off uh it's the
threat that i can invoke it
that keeps you on the straight and
narrow so in equilibrium i actually
don't play the punishment strategy
right this is like you know if you have
kids it's like this threat that if you
do this
you will get the severe punishment the
kids don't do it and you never have to
invoke the punishment strategy
but knowing that it's there is important
it prevents them from deviating right so
okay okay yeah that explains it because
i was on the impression that punishment
strategy is something that
uh is part of the game already well it
it exists
so i mean that is it there's some you
know in other words
you imagine you tell a kid that you know
if i catch you
cheating you know i won't let you play
on the computer for a whole week
and that's a horrible punishment um and
and
uh and and you know if
it's such a bad punishment that that you
know the child might
might never deviate might you know never
be bad because
they don't want to get punished right so
and that's what in equilibrium
you don't play the punishment strategy
it's enough of a threat
that that that you don't have to invoke
it but it's important that
that it's possible to invoke it right in
the same sense as you know you can
imagine with kids that
you know there's no way you can prevent
me from playing on the computer because
um you know i can get it from my cell
phone or something you know i
right so if if the fact that you
if you know about sequential equilibrium
there is a concern
very much if you're if you're a parent
you know that you know you can threaten
something will you actually carry out
the punishment if
if you have to right um and
other so is it if you're in the
situation that you're not supposed to
get to where
where there's a deviation and you catch
it will you carry out the punishment
strategy
because the punishment strategy will
also make you worse off
and what we've shown is that there you
can actually implement a sequential
equilibrium where
um it's rational to carry out the
punishment
um if
you know if if you're in a position
where you have to so
that's a stronger notion of equilibrium
in the nash equilibrium it's a
sequential equilibrium but
we we can actually implement the
sequential electricity
so has that answered the question yes
yes
okay uh other questions
neil so um
corner cooperman presented
maybe in this seminar or in the other
one uh sort of the model checking
question when it has to do with nash
equilibrium and
sort of k nash equilibrium so
does does the model checking
question for kt robust equilibrium
makes sense or do i not understand
something fundamental
so good question i so how did ona
model the model checking problem
well the the results that you presented
uh are you know in general if i give you
uh
you know any type of game with a
moderator i can convert or there exists
a game that for which doesn't run right
the model checking question would be
consider this particular game these
particular
[Music]
objectives and then we need to analyze
it and we need to say
for this particular game it does yeah so
it seems to me
it so the question is which game you'd
want to analyze
so i guess it would i mean certainly
would be very interesting to
you know we presented an implementation
right so what's our implementation it's
a strategy it's a protocol
that we claim implements the mediator um
we believe that our protocol is correct
we certainly tried to check
the proof very carefully but we
certainly did not run a model checker
on it um so you could say that that um
could we take our so the interesting
protocol would be not
typically the protocol with the
mediators is is fairly simple
um the hard part is the implementation
and you know when
players are just talking to each other
so it certainly makes sense to ask
is the um is our implementation correct
is do we in fact have a kt robust
protocol
without the mediator that gets the same
equilibrium that you got
with the mediator now to make sense out
of that i think you'd need
well which i assume i did as well you'd
need to bring in
utilities right because
you know things like punishment
strategies are you know not meaningful
if you can't
talk about utilities but it seems to me
in principle once you had a sufficiently
rich specification language
that could talk about utilities you
could at least in principle model check
that um our implementation and and
hopefully show that that it really does
implement the nash equilibrium that we
claim it does
right so that you know we have the nash
equilibrium with the mediator
so that would be your spec right do you
get
this nash equilibrium in the
communication game where the players are
just talking to each other without a
mediator
um
prove that this strategy which is fairly
common the strategy
involves um
sort of like a multi-party computation
where we're simulating step by step
what the mediator is doing while
preserving
secrecy um so we're using techniques
from cryptography to
to literally the players on their own
are
simulating the mediator that's that's
what happens in in our communication
game
so i would think that that verifying
that our strategy that simulates the
mediator
is indeed doing what we claim it does um
would be non-trivial and certainly at
least in principle something could try
to verify
i'm not sure that i asked the right
question okay try again
thank you and i think yeah thank you for
the talk it was great
um other questions
there's a question from sally uh i think
you should be able to unmute yourself
and ask the question directly
please go ahead
uh if not maybe i can just read it out
for you so hi joe
great talk could you elaborate a bit
more on partial synchrony as for example
assumed in blockchain
paradigms how partial is partial
synchrony without turning to being
asynchronous
so the big difference so in partial
synchrony there's assumed to be a
commonly known
upper bound on message delivery time
so if i send a message to rupak suppose
the upper bound to seven
it's guaranteed that it will get there
within seven rounds
so there's assumed in the background to
be a a clock that's
you know we could talk about round one
round two round three round four
every message is guaranteed to arrive
within seven rounds
could be less and that's the problem
that um if some messages arrive
quickly then i might you know it might
be a good strategy for me to wait
before sending my messages to see if i
can get some messages that arrive
quickly and then
my message can depend on those messages
right so that that's called a rushing
adversary in in the literature
and that's the kind of thing that the
people doing blockchain are very worried
about
so obviously if you can do something
in an asynchronous setting it's
guaranteed to work in a partially
synchronous
setting so
so that's that's the key difference
there's not bound to message delivery
time
and um i think it's assumed typically
that
if you want to send a message you can so
that there's no
scheduler deciding who gets to send the
message when as there would be in an
asynchronous setting
but as i say the just the fact that
messages can take up the delta to arrive
and that some can arrive earlier than
others so if all messages took
exactly seven rounds to arrive then you
might as well be in the synchronous
setting
right then replace seven you know
call a seven round block one round one
super round and
and you're back in the synchronous set
right so what makes it
complicated is some messages might
arrive
faster than others and an adversary can
take advantage of the fact
that messages have arrived early and
that turns out to be
quite difficult and subtle to deal with
sometimes
and as i say obviously any algorithm
that works in the asynchronous setting
is guaranteed to work in the partially
significant setting
as well so um you know one way of just
dealing with it is is
just to get an algorithm that works even
in the asynchronous setting
so so does that address your question
thanks maybe i have one more question so
you talked about uh
obedient players but i guess you can
also model
a certain class of players who are
unaware of the rules of the game
so the kind of examples that you had
about irrationality was about
unawareness of the that's that can
certainly be one interpretation of
unawareness of
of irrationality that an example i often
give
uh is you know imagine my mother trying
to bid on ebay my mother was hopeless on
the internet
never really learned how to use a
computer um so
you can imagine somebody who you know
just
really doesn't understand the rules of
the game at all and is unaware of the
rules the game
so you do have to assume that they
understand at least
what actions are possible but um
they may have no clue what they're
supposed to do or
i think that's very much the case so
again it seems to me if i was building
something like you know a bidding system
like ebay where there could be thousands
of players
you need to build in a certain amount of
robustness you can't assume that
everybody
you know using the protocol is an expert
so that you know sometimes the actions
that you're seeing
are not rational deviations it's not
that somebody's been sitting there
saying
okay what can i do to get an extra
dollar it's that somebody's sitting
there saying
uh i have no clue
of what to do so i'm going to do this
not because i'm
trying to get an extra dollar but you
know because i really don't understand
what's going on
right and and it seems to me that if
you're a system designer trying to build
a large system
you definitely want to build in a
certain amount of robustness
now i think it's reasonable to assume
and that's why we had the parameters
that
look okay some people are going to be
newbies some people are going to be
clueless but
you know no more than 10 of the total
people
using the system are going to be like
that so you know you
take t to be like 10 right um
that's that's the idea
that that um and those players
because they're you know don't
understand what's going on they're not
doing things for rational reasons
they're not trying to get an extra
dollar
just want to make sure they can't hurt
you right so that was the motivation for
our definition of
robustness or immunity technically right
thank you so much okay are there any
other questions
if not uh let me thank uh joe from all
of us it's a bit difficult to do it
virtually
yes thank you again for this wonderful
talk
and and for the rest of us
uh we meet again next week
at the same time thank you again bye-bye
thank you